la comisión europea no financiará a
ninguna alambrada entre los países del
bloque y belarús así lo afirmo usula
vanderlei en al término de la cumbre de
la unión europea en bruselas la gran
discusión fue la postura de polonia
sobre la migración la votaban tendrá un
nuevo fondo dedicado a la innovación
militar los ministros de defensa
firmaron un pacto para invertir mil
millones de euros su primera estrategia
será fortalecer la inteligencia
artificial en los países de la alianza
y la comunidad cinematográfica
estadounidense se solidariza con las
víctimas del accidente de infolive el
actor alec baldwin le disparó con una
pistola supuestamente de utilería a la
directora de fotografía salina hastings
y luego ella murió
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy manejé a la calle y es un placer
saludarlos
comenzamos hablando de la presidenta de
la comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
quien afirmó que no habrá dinero para
las alambradas entre los países así
respondió a lituania y polonia que ha
pedido de levantar un cerco en sus
fronteras con belarús todo para frenar
el paso de los migrantes von der leyen
afirmó que el gobierno bielorruso está
fomentando la migración en represalia
por las sanciones escuchemos lo que dijo
en la cumbre europea
es funding off
el presupuesto europeo financia la
gestión de las fronteras y por supuesto
no solo el equipo o parte del personal
también toda la electrónica necesaria y
la denominada infraestructura física o
social actúan extra de hecho hubo una
discusión sobre esta and in the west y
dejé muy claro que hay un comentario de
larga data en la comisión y con el
parlamento europeo de que no habrá
financiamiento de alambradas ni de muros
para le mans dt web vino funding of wood
wire and walls y esto fue lo que dijo
von der leyen en la cumbre de los
líderes europeos durante las reuniones
los dirigentes también aprovecharon para
discutir temas como la migración la
subida de los precios de la energía y la
transición climática entre otros uno de
los puntos más difíciles es la situación
con polonia porque el país dice que las
leyes nacionales sobre migración priman
sobre el derecho de la unión europea
hungría y república checa- respaldan a
este país en contra de las naciones del
norte alva santana tiene todos los
detalles
fin de la cumbre de la unión europea
durante dos jornadas en los líderes del
bloque discutieron sobre la crisis
migratoria en el viejo continente y
acordaron nuevas sanciones contra
belarús por usar como arma la entrada de
inmigrantes a europa
andrés en instrumental de 6 nov
migration
esto es una instrumentalización de la
migración para presionar políticamente a
la unión europea por eso mantendremos la
presión sobre el régimen de lukashenko
ya hemos propuesto la revocación de
visas para el régimen y sus aliados y
estamos listos para estudiar más
sanciones ex proxies no sólo contra
individuos sino que contra entidades y
compañías también individuales para el
software chis o companies ante los ojos
de la unión europea polonia también ha
cruzado una línea roja ya que el país
antepuso la ley nacional a la
intercomunitaria pero el bloque de los
27 asegura que está dispuesto a dialogar
en busca de una solución es impotente
es política es importante gestionar este
tema políticamente y tener un diálogo
escuchamos el fuerte mensaje de varios
líderes
con los esfuerzos para mantener un
diálogo político
para escucharnos los unos a los otros y
entender cuáles son los problemas
exactos para conseguir soluciones y dino
de tus libros solución otro tema central
fue el alza de precios de la energía
para solucionar este problema
la web planifica a corto plazo que los
estados inviertan en ayudas para los
hogares y a largo plazo establecer una
posible reserva estratégica de gas común
y estudiar el estado del mercado el
compromiso climático y la transición
digital también estuvieron sobre la mesa
finalizando la jornada los líderes
europeos aprovecharon para despedirse de
angela merkel con una ovación tras
ocupar el puesto de canciller de
alemania por 16 años
bruselas también fue el escenario de
otra reunión la de la otan la
organización destinará mil millones de
euros para la innovación militar y es
que los ministros de defensa de la
alianza del norte le apuestan a la
inteligencia artificial para
contrarrestar el poder de rusia y sus
avances militares veamos el informe
diez mil soldados rusos cientos de
tanques y decenas de aviones y buques de
guerra entrenando en la frontera
ucraniana estás imágenes de abril han
dejado su huella en la mente de los
países de la otan el jueves la alianza
atlántica adoptó una nueva estrategia
enteramente dedicada a la defensa contra
rusia
no vamos a imitar el comportamiento
desestabilizador de rusia y no tenemos
intención de desplegar nuevos misiles
nucleares en suelo europeo
por ello estamos reforzando un paquete
de medidas políticas y militares para
responder a esta amenaza
3.3 el escenario que la otan prevé en su
nuevo plan un ataque simultáneo de rusia
en las regiones del báltico y el mar
negro potencialmente con armas
prototípicas nucleares ataques
informáticos y ataques desde el espacio
para preparar su defensa la alianza
cuenta con un fondo de mil millones de
dólares se utilizará para financiar la
innovación y la modernización de su
arsenal mientras los estados miembros
están alarmados por las últimas
tecnologías militares rusas como un
misil hipersónico o robots de combate
desplegados hace unas semanas durante
los ejercicios contra bielorrusia sin
embargo la alianza especifica que no
espera un ataque inminente de rusia y
apelamos a
la otan debe seguir haciendo lo que ha
hecho hasta ahora prepararse la mano de
la audaz y entendida rusia debe
aprovechar las angustiantes de rusia por
su parte ni a cualquier hostilidad hacia
los países europeos y considera que es
la otan la que corre el riesgo de
desestabilizar el continente con estos
preparativos
hablamos ahora del cobi 19 porque el
resurgimiento de la pandemia en asia
impacta el sector automotriz la escasez
de componentes electrónicos ha puesto en
aprietos a la francesa renault medio
millón de sus automóviles no saldrán de
la línea de producción en 2021
es una pérdida de 500 mil automóviles y
gigante francés renaud reducirá su
producción medio millón de vehículos no
saldrán a la venta más del doble de lo
que habían predicho hace un mes la
industria automotriz en todo el mundo ha
estado luchando ante la escasez de
semiconductores un componente esencial
lo que está provocando el aumento de los
precios de los vehículos
en esta fábrica de reno se detuvo la
producción durante dos semanas y en esta
planta en el este de francia también se
ha paralizado la actividad de tensión ha
pasado una semana y es frustrante
moralmente es difícil para los empleados
saber que no podemos fabricar porque no
tenemos las piezas allí se fabrican
vehículos comerciales pero en los
últimos cinco días 2000 empleados han
sido despedidos
primero el joven y ahora los componentes
que escasean no ha sido fácil el
resurgimiento de la pandemia en asia
donde se producen los semiconductores es
lo que está causando el déficit para
algunos sindicatos traslada la
producción a francia podría resolver el
problema uno de composición tenemos
algunas ideas tenemos programada una
reunión para la semana que viene para
proponer la fabricación de
semiconductores en francia
sugerimos que se haga cerca de nuestras
fábricas para que podamos arreglar
nuestra cadena de suministros reno
registró una pérdida del 20 por ciento
en ventas en su tercer trimestre además
sus ingresos cayeron a poco menos de
nueve mil millones de euros un 13% menos
que en 2020 durante el mismo período
francia y eeuu intentan restablecer la
confianza mutua el presidente francés
emmanuel bajó y su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden hablaron
telefónicamente de este viernes el
elíseo sostuvo que están trabajando para
afrontar juntos desafíos como una
defensa europea más fuerte ambos países
se distanciaron luego de que la casa
blanca firmara el pacto august con
australia para construir submarinos de
propulsión nuclear por esto francia
perdió un millonario contrato
y el ministro de defensa de eeuu lloyd
austin afirmó que su país continuará
apoyando taiwán para defenderse el
presidente joe biden ya había dicho que
defendería a la isla si beijing la ataca
hoy china respondió advirtiéndole al
gobierno norteamericano que hablara con
cautela alva santana tiene el reporte es
una advertencia clara dirigida a joe
biden china no tiene intención de hacer
confesiones con el tema de taiwán
eeuu debe actuar y hablar con cautela
sobre la cuestión de taiwán y abstenerse
de enviar señales erróneas a las fuerzas
separatistas de ese país esto para
evitar dañar seriamente las relaciones
chino-estadounidenses
no se oponga a los 1400 millones de
chinos este mensaje llega después de que
el presidente by ben dijera que su país
defendería a taiwán en caso de que china
intentará hacerse con el control de la
isla autogobernada una declaración que
contradice la política exterior de eeuu
que ayuda a construir defensas en taiwán
sin prometer explícitamente su
asistencia en caso de guerra no obstante
la casa blanca aseguró más tarde que su
postura al respecto
no ha cambiado china considera a taiwán
como territorio nacional y ha prometido
controlarla algún día utilizando la
fuerza si es necesario con 23 millones
de habitantes taiwán es una de las
democracias más progresistas de asia y
la presidenta chagin wen ha rechazado la
propuesta de chimpín de establecer el
modelo de un país con dos sistemas
independientes como en el caso de hong
kong y macao su negativa está enfadando
a beijing que ha intensificado las
maniobras militares cerca de la isla
haciendo volar aviones de combate en el
espacio aéreo de taiwán y navegando con
buques de guerra a su alrededor desde el
pasado mes de septiembre se han
realizado más de 800 vuelos y sobre lo
que va de mes 170
y hollywood llora la muerte de la
directora de fotografía alinea hatching
el actor alec baldwin le disparó por
error con una pistola que se suponía era
parte de la utilería los hechos
ocurrieron en nuevo mexico durante el
rodaje del western rasta hatching
falleció cuando estaba en el hospital y
el director del film joel shows ya
también resultó herido así se pronunció
el actor en su cuenta de twitter
no hay palabras para transmitir mi
conmoción y tristeza por el trágico
accidente que se cobró la vida de alina
hutchings esposa madre y colega nuestra
profundamente admirada estoy cooperando
plenamente con la investigación policial
para abordar como ocurrió esta tragedia
y estoy en contacto con su esposo
ofreciéndole mi apoyo a él ya su familia
mi corazón está roto por su esposo su
hijo y todos los que conocieron y amaron
a lina en noticias de américa latina' el
presidente de ecuador guillermo lasso
estaría obstaculizando la investigación
en su contra por las revelaciones de los
papeles de pandora así lo consideró la
comisión de garantías constitucional de
la asamblea nacional ecuatoriana la
comisión lo citó por segunda vez para
que rindiera su testimonio sin embargo
las o no ha ido en ninguna de las dos
ocasiones y la presidencia alega que
responderá a las preguntas únicamente
desde el palacio de gobierno y después
de que todos los testigos comparezcan
esto es lo que dice la comisión
la nueva
en asistencia del presidente de la
república al seno de esta comisión
obstaculiza seriamente
esta investigación y obstruye de manera
intencionada la labor de la asamblea
nacional de ejercer control político y
fiscalización
a los actos de los y
y las servidores públicas también en
ecuador la reforma del código orgánico
integral penal permite la producción
distribución y comercialización del
cannabis para el uso medicinal desde
2019 un floricultor de rosas decidió
apostarle a la siembra de cannabis pese
a que las flores son son el primer rubro
de exportación del país andino nuestro
corresponsal en quito- gustavo ortega
tiene esta historia
crea ser siembra rosas en este puerto
desde hace 35 años
pero ha decidido cambiarse de rubro
y apostar al cannabis para uso medicinal
las hectáreas que se van a migrar a
cannabis con hectáreas nuevas de rosas
no no tengo ninguna interna las rosas
pero sí creo que esta es una industria
con un potencial enorme y las ventajas
que tiene ecuador como país
tiene ventajas que ningún otro país del
mundo las tiene las rosas son el
principal producto de exportación en
ecuador sin embargo con la reforma del
código orgánico integral penal se ha
abierto una nueva línea de negocios a
los productores y trabajo para la mano
de obra pero aún hay barreras por
derribar al principio los estigmas que
decían que no que debería retirarme
porque había supuestamente que la planta
la de decían que era mala que nos servía
que no se montó en estigmas que le decía
pero con el tiempo fuimos viendo que no
era cierto
laboratorios y ecuatorianos ya están
preparando medicamentos con cannabis
películas de epilepsia agradece que ya
esté disponible esa opción medicinal en
su país que yo me caigo me quedo en un
piso y después como que reaccionó
con un poco del dolor de cabeza y
entonces no me he dado cuenta de eso
pero ahora con las gotitas he podido
controlarlo mucho mejor
no he podido ya no me da en la mañana en
la noche pocas veces esto de aquí se
vende así klaus además de rosas ahora
vende sus recetas de cannabis y que el
mercado por ahora se mantendrá con los
dos rubros a la espera de resultados
económicos para ver si se concentra sólo
en este nuevo negocio
para más noticias sobre nuestra región y
en nuestro idioma sigan conectados las
24 horas con france 24 y recuerden
también seguirnos en nuestras redes
sociales nos vemos en una próxima
ocasión
[Música]